in a recent video I discussed William
PK's book Crusade and Jihad the
Thousand-Year war between the Muslim
world and the global North keyword
Thousand-Year war and although it is as
you can see a mighty Tome containing 550
pages and Al although it claims to cover
a thousand years most of those years of
conflict from 634 when Islam really
first invaded Western Christian lands to
the 1800 when it went on the retreat
received only some 30 pages of coverage
as we saw in other words those 12
centuries which saw Muslims conquer most
of Christendom original territory and
invade more with all the attended
massacres and destruction and
enslavement Des spoilation of churches
converting them into mosques Etc
received a few sanitized Pages mostly
alluding to how Islam spread through
trade and the glories of Al loose if you
haven't seen that video link in
description so what is the rest of his
book about in fact about 520 of its 550
pages that is to say 95% of the book is
confined to the last two centuries when
Europe ceased being on the defensive and
went on the offensive against Islam here
pulk meticulously describes in Vivid and
hyperbolic detail every conceivable sin
the West committed against Muslims
here's a quote beginning at various
times after Christopher Columbus led the
way across the Atlantic and the
Portuguese plunged down the West African
Coast the actions of the north have been
uniformly destructive and sometimes
genocidal the first cause of the danger
and insecurity he's referring to Islamic
terrorism today we feel today is the
long history of imperialism a century or
more of invasion occupation humiliation
and genocide from the West to Muslims
has left scars that are still not healed
and cannot heal if if they are
constantly
reopened of course having whitewashed
the first Millennium of jihad on the
west as he does it's easy for pulk to
make Europeans appear as the unprovoked
aggressors greedy monsters come to
destroy the glories of Islam yet he
fails to mention that Columbus sailed
West precisely because the Mediterranean
was an Islamic Terror Zone with turkic
ottomans and Egyptian mamluk
slaughtering and enslaving any Christian
that got into their hands
and he presents Russian expansion into
Tatar regions as a merciless Enterprise
without explaining that the tatars known
in Russian Chronicles as the Heathen
giant who feeds on our blood terrorize
and enslaves Russians for centuries
earlier as more balanced historians such
as Bernard Lewis have explained quote
the whole complex process of European
expansion and Empire he's referring to
colonial era has its roots in The Clash
of Islam and Christendom it began with a
long and bitter struggle of the
conquered peoples of Europe in east and
west to restore their homelands to
Christendom and expel the Muslim peoples
who had invaded and subjugated them it
was hardly to be expected that the
triumphant Spaniards and
Portuguese would stop at the Straits of
Gibralter or that the Russians would
allow the tatars to retire in peace and
regroup in their bases on the upper and
lower vulga the more so since a new and
deadly Muslim attack on Christendom was
already underway the Victorious
liberators having reconquered their own
territories pursued their former Masters
the Muslims whence they had come such as
the start of the colonial era regardless
pul habitually harps on how quote
memories so this is pul talking now
quote memories of Western imperialism
are deep among Muslims and they helped
create much of the world's disorder and
danger
today terrorism the humiliation and
wholesale massacres of populations
carried out by European imperialists
though largely forgotten by the
perpetrators the West remain today Vivid
to the descendants of the
victims as such every Islamic terror
group including the Islamic State Isis
are the products of the anger and
frustration of Muslims which has its
roots according to pul and others in the
colonial era again one need only look to
Real History not fake history to
appreciate the Folly of his
deterministic reading which sees Muslims
as the Perpetual victims of a fake
history after a millennium of actual
European victimhood a millennium of
Muslim invasions that saw the conquest
of three quarters of Christendom
original territory the enslavement of 5
million Europeans between just the 15th
and 18th centuries at the hands mostly
of barbar pirates the tatars the
aforementioned tatars and the Ottomans
and after the slaugh of Untold Millions
backwards Europe still managed to rise
triumphant and without any apologies or
appeasement from Muslims why can't Islam
could it be that its problems are
intrinsic and have nothing to do with
the purported sins of Europe for
instance in PK's chapter Somalia the
fail State imperialism is again cited as
the blame all yet In 1855 decades before
Europeans colonized it the adventurer
Richard Burton described Somalia in very
unappealing terms terms adding that
somalis are quote extremely bigoted
especially against Christians and are
fond of jiading unquote today Somalia
remains one of the world's most failed
States Barone al-shabab the youth is its
jihadist Vanguard and any Somali outed
as a Christian is beheaded is European
colonialism really necessary to explain
such continuity